as uk intelligence suggests russia could
invade at any moment
joining us is politics expert and
historian natalia nakatoshkaya who was a
vice chair of the international affairs
committee for russia's state duma hello
to you thank you for joining us on the
programme
oh thank you for inviting me thank you
what do you think is going to happen
well
i think nothing will happen if there is
no provocation on the part of ukrainian
uh nazis
because i
strongly believe that uh ukrainian
government is controlled by these
galician
nationalists
who have
been hitler's collaborators and they are
just full of hatred
you know almost
zoological anti-semitism and
anti-russophobia
so if there is no provocation on the
part of ukraine or sponsored by the west
because i think it's the west especially
i'm sorry to say uncle saxons the
british and the americans who wants very
much to persuade the whole world that
russia is going to invade
cui bono
why should russia invade what will
russia again just invading
another problem is when there is
provocation and the bombs will start
falling on the heads of russians and
donetsk and lugansk
regions
who do not agree with the policy of
modern ukraine
then of course there will be a hard
issue for russians whether to interfere
but only in that case
so there's no provocation no invasion at
all
russia has never intended to invade
ukraine
why i wonder have they put 130 000
troops on the border
well uh russian troops are stationed on
russian territory and russia has right
to
have their troops and move them around
on
its own territory so why should it
signify that it's going to invade
you know
if there is provocation given without
stationing troops along the border
it's
very easy to
to
fight back
any attack
but the situation
is and you perfectly well know
that
it is the west
who supplies now ukraine with enormous
amount of arms and
ukrainian um
nationalists concentrate
uh on the line uh between
the mainland and the nest and lugansk
region even forbidden uh types of arms
etc so the situation is aggravating so
i think any country is allowed to just
to be prepared especially that the
situation
on the south you know
is is not uh very calm i mean not not in
the south of russia but i mean in the
black sea and caucasian
region
with
turkey
having
you know dreams to reinstate the
osmonian empire and to become a
formidable porter
now so
this is a general situation um
in
global geopolitics that
perhaps
[Music]
if the troops there's 130 000 russian
troops that the number has been
increasing significantly over the last
month or so but but your interpretation
of that madam is that um they're there
purely in a defensive role in case
ukraine decides to invade russia
but of course but i i don't think only
someone
totally mad and in delirious
geopolitical
speculations can enrage russia because
uh
well i
i understand that
it is perfectly known why do they need
to be there then if it's unlikely that
you know that could ever happen
why put the troops there then
well because of the general situation
just just to to make sure that if
anything happens russia is ready but
russia certainly doesn't have any
intention to fight russia insisted uh
has always
insisted on
implementation in full range of minsk
negotiations and decisions and
agreements and it's ukraine that doesn't
want even and practically openly
declares that means
negotiations and agreements um do not
fit ukrainian interests i don't know why
that means ukraine doesn't want to
to to settle the situation
okay that's that's very deplorable
and
it's concentrating for me um
yeah may i ask you this question i
wonder if i could ask you this please
madam um and that is what if ukraine
decides
um that they are going to join
nato would that be sufficient
provocation for russia to decide to take
matters further
well
well
russian position was stated clearly
and bluntly that
for us it is inadmissible that uh
ukraine joins nato just imagine if uh
mexico
or anyone on the border of the united
states
would have joined
the warsaw pact you know you remember
what happened when
soviet union stationed some rockets on
cuba what
what
did the united states uh declare then
there was a provocation of course and
russia yielded and i mean the soviet
union so for us it's absolutely
geopolitically inadmissible fact but
even in that case i do not think russia
would invade ukraine russia would
make some other and very serious
steps um
there are
many
ways we can react to this because russia
is very strong now military and
contrary to the
public opinion
myths in the west it is quite united
i mean there is a public consent with
regard to foreign policy there are many
other protesting
attitudes
especially in the economics but as far
as foreign russian foreign policy and
position of our president and
mr lavrov is
russia is united moreover i would like
to say that
compared to the average russian opinion
mr president mr putin is a dumb of peace
you know
although
you may
laugh at this
of course my joke but
the average russian
is much more angry with the western
policies and jerusalem in media and
media history against russia so
they
i mean russian people in general and i
measure always the public opinion
it is
couldn't care less anymore about what
foreign press
rates about russia
yeah i i wonder you know
i wonder i wonder if if this morning
some of my viewers would agree that uh
president putin is a colossus of peace
when we look at
an airline that was shot down mh17 and
people killed by poison on the streets
of a quiet city here in the uk but
that's a discussion for another day i
suppose what i'd like to ask you
in conclusion is when do you think the
british the russian troops will be
moving back from the border with ukraine
i wish i could
elaborate on this topic but you know
about poisoning etc why should we
believe uh
you know
the
data of some intelligence after
colin powell
test tube etc so no nobody is really
taking seriously
um things because there were no proofs
at all but that's another
issue we'll
not talk about it now
no
i believe that if the situation relaxes
if there is uncount
which we all want
then there won't be any reason to keep
forces i mean armed forces and troops
[Music]
such scale but i believe and i would
like to reiterate that russia's
sovereign country
has right to have
troops anywhere and doesn't mean
it is intending to invade anyone
okay okay it's it's absolutely
fascinating to speak to you uh this
morning madam sadly we are out of time
but hopefully you'll be able to come
back and talk to us again very soon
thank you very much indeed
thank you thank you very much